it looks like apple is finally ready to
take the m1 ipad pro seriously and
finally turn it into a pro device
according to a bunch of rumors reports
and some new leaks as well so in this
video i'm gonna go through all of that
and share my thoughts on when and how
apple is gonna make it pro again now the
first thing we're gonna start off with
is a brand new power on newsletter
report from mark german who is by the
way one of the most reliable apple
leakers out there and he says that the
ipad's hardware has long been ahead of
its software and a possible solution is
a new pro mode that kicks in when you're
connected to a keyboard and trackpad and
that is exactly what apple has with
their magic keyboard and let me tell you
it's expensive but it is absolutely
mind-blowing when you use it even with
the current software it just works so
well however
last year with ipad os 15 a lot of
people were so disappointed because they
were expecting a lot of new software and
features to take advantage of the m1
chip because all of us thought hey
they're finally giving it a ton of power
with the m1 that means they're giving it
a ton of new features and guess what
they didn't do it they didn't deliver
and that's why we created this video
saying how apple just ruined the m1 ipad
pro with ipad os 15 it got a lot of
views and there was a lot of people who
were upset and we even came back and
talked about it again and yet there are
so many disappointments with what apple
did for example they give it up to 16
gigs of ram but apps can't even take
advantage of all of that it's just so
disappointing but finally according to
mark german there is a new possible
solution that apple could take which is
that new pro mode to take advantage of
the m1 and of course the m2 ipad pro
which a lot of leakers are expecting at
the end of this year yes in the fall and
i personally believe we're getting it a
hundred percent just based on apple's
timelines about a year and a half to two
years in between ipad pro releases so i
think the m2 is coming and i think with
ipad os 16 apple is going to give it
some major feature changes now with that
said mark german had a twitter spaces
with federico vittisi from mac stories
and he has a new option that apple could
take having three different modes based
on what your ipad is doing so for
example if you just have the ipad it's
using the standard touch first mode now
when you grab an apple pencil and
connect it it starts to optimize the
icons the controls and the interface to
match the apple pencil and make it work
the best for that but now the new third
pro mode kicks in when you grab the
magic keyboard or an external keyboard
that has a keyboard and a trackpad built
in and then it brings it into that pro
mode and in terms of what it'll actually
offer first of all you're going to be
able to get mac like multi-tasking or
the ability to run several windows on
top of each other and next to each other
so basically just like you have on a mac
or a pc you got windows over here here
here they're all resizable and all
running alongside each other without
having to do like a split screen and
then a slide over window that's just not
that good we're finally getting real
multitasking now on top of that he
thinks we're going to get a more dynamic
dock where we can pin files and have
minimized apps into it where you can
kind of hold down you have a bunch of
extra information pop up so that is much
needed i think it's going to be a great
help and then finally a proper desktop
not just the home screen but an actual
desktop like we have on a mac or a
macbook where you can drag and drop
files and folders keep them all there
you have dynamic widgets and he even
thinks we're going to be able to get
miniature apps so let's say you have a
little music app just pops up floats
right there or potentially a new
calculator app apple tv remote sticky
notes so everything can have just a
little window pops up right there just
like you have for example
calculator out look at that just move it
everywhere i hope we get something like
this and if you're struggling to imagine
how this could potentially look like we
actually have on twitter parker ordolani
who made some ipad os 16 concepts so
check this out as you can see right here
if you zoom in you can see some new
features first of all in the
multitasking window you have different
sets of windows or apps with everything
minimized and then on top of that you
have some extra little miniature apps up
here so you're having both of them
visible on the screen at the same time
so it's easier to navigate and then if
you look over here on the left you
actually have your downloads folder with
a little pop-up window with your
downloads just like we have on the mac
up here we have the little music widget
manager window that popped up over here
we have the triple windows right there
as you can see parker imagined the app
pairing so having better multitasking
three or four apps at once and entirely
new app layouts right over here where
you can split the screen up in different
ways so have maps on the right safari on
the top you can even put mail on the
bottom so triple multitasking like that
customized to your own liking and even
better 95 mac actually has an article
where they showed some close-ups of
these different features and as you can
see right here you can now pin
different music podcast books shows
files directly to the home screen as you
can see right here you got the daring
fireball talk show all that kind of
stuff and now
this is what i really really want studio
mode where apple finally fixes the
external display issues that we have
right now where you hook it up and you
just get this like square-ish display
instead of utilizing the whole thing i
think apple should fix it with ipad os
16. and this is actually a leak from
john prosser from a couple of years ago
almost to the t
2020 april 22nd he said he's 100
confident that final cut pro logic pro
and xcode are coming to the ipad pro and
the reason i am so confident in this
happening is because of a leak from
imagine boo on twitter he said that
apple is working on a version of final
cut for the ipad now going even further
imaginable also says that according to
his sources there's gonna be a new guest
account that should be arriving on the
ipad and going even further he says that
apple is developing a smart system for
ipad os where apps will continue to open
full screen but then automatically
shrink when connected to keyboard and
trackpad and this fully matches up to
what mark german was saying so it's
basically like the apps get minimized
and you go into this new pro mode and
the most interesting part out of all
this is that he said it should be m1
ipad exclusive so if you're wondering
why apple gave the m1 chip to the ipad
air well there is your answer because
the ipad air also supports the magic
keyboard so if you can get a magic
keyboard and an m1 ipad air or ipad pro
you have access to all of these new
awesome pro mode features and going
further here's yet another ipad os 16
leak by imagine boot where he says
there's going to be stacks of files in
the doc apps that is going to be
arriving and you're going to possibly be
able to activate it with the apple
pencil so as you can see you have your
dock and you click on one and it opens
up a bunch of different apps kind of
like in a list and now with that said i
think that if apple actually gives us
this new pro mode with the new features
i think it's going to be a very big deal
at wwdc in june because it's not only
going to matter for the future ipads but
even the current ones that people have
like the m1 ipad pro that is actually
going to fix the ipad pro for a lot of
people and we're going to see a lot of
people start buying that again because
of the new software optimizations and
it's going to be a very big deal but
we are expecting the m2 ipad pro coming
this fall and that's gonna of course
come with the new chip but also there
are a lot of leaks and rumors that we
should be expecting
mag safe connectivity so yes wireless
mac safe so as you can see right here i
think that the next upcoming version of
the magic keyboard is going to support
max save charging just plop it onto the
back right here and it's going to pass
through the magic keyboard and charge
the ipad pro so that's going to be very
very nice so i think this is going to be
a huge deal and i think that ipad west
16 is going to be a lot better than a
lot of us are expecting i think it's
just going to blow a lot of people away
and i think it's finally going to make
the ipad pro a competitive machine in
terms of being a laptop replacement so
with that said hopefully you enjoyed
this video and if you did go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]